hello ten oh and welcome to Playstation
grenade how are things going for you in
warframe what planets have you most
recently unlocked I'm about to venture
into Saturn but one day I shall see
Uranus and that's the last joke of the
video I promise in our last episode we
went over the basics of warframe and how
to approach it from a beginner's point
of view if you haven't seen it I'll
throw a link in the comments below I
recommend watching that to see if you
can put up with my annoying voice on
this journey in this episode we are
going to build our first warframe
together locating blueprints customizing
our ships and what the heck you should
be spending your Platinum on oh and
we'll do some void fishes stuff too the
links to each section are below if you
want to jump around to any specifics or
replay any segments the first thing
we're going to do though is look at many
issues which people had whilst
attempting to unlock the Phobos Junction
on Mars we touched on it last episode
each Junction has requirements to be met
before we can unlock the node these are
here to teach us the game's mechanics
but they scare many people away from the
game than they probably should what in
particular is driving users insane and I
have to admit the game does a terrible
job of conveying what on earth you
should be doing or rather what on Mars
you should be doing so here's the Phobos
Junction checklist defeat 150 enemies in
a single mission easy enough yeah by the
way if you're not sure how many people
you've murdered simply press options and
check the mission report to be certain
it is in fact the second one of these
requirements that confuses and
infuriates so many people scan 3
Cephalon fragments on mars the fragments
are these glowing objects randomly found
around many missions how the [ __ ] do we
scan them many people are screaming at
their screens well it starts back on
your ship jump on the market and search
for a codec scanner it may look like a
bull's head but this is actually an item
like a military pair of binoculars you
will need these so buy a bunch of them
they are super cheap so don't be stingy
next we need to put these in our
warframes imaginary backpack so bullet
jump down to your arsenal and at the
bottom just above emotes is a gear slot
clicking on this brings up a wheel
we'll probably be completely bare it
won't be for long it will be filled up
very soon
choose a slot to you like the best and
equip your codec scanner once that's
complete go back into missions on Mars
and hunt down those glowing fragments
when you finally stumble across a
fragment press down on your d-pad and
select the scanner pressing the aim
button will now bring up the scanner to
your eyes and the fire button becomes a
scan function and that's it you don't
understad finding three of these little
blighters can be frustrating but there's
one every mission on Mars so keep
looking round the randomly generated
environment and you should find it if
you choose to the scammed fragments are
actually lore updates in your codex but
who wants to read if you're having any
issues trying to find these there are
quite a few mods which will help you
spot fragments through walls
I'll put icons on your screen to find
them too so now we have two out of the
three requirements needed to open the
junction but the third node once again
introduces a new element to the game's
mechanics open three lifts void relics
which is pretty good because I wanted to
talk about void fissures here anyway
does the game give you a clue how to
open void relics now that would be way
too easy when you get to this point I'm
sure you've already noticed random
conquers you've been picking up our
bronze lettuces or of brown cabbages if
you prefer
well these bad boys are actually void
relics on your ship they are hidden
behind the corner next to your arsenal
open up the menu and by highlighting
over each relic type you can see a list
of possible loot inside at this point I
should say you really want to get former
out of these relics it's another form of
currency which is vital later in the
game those forward-thinking players will
always gravitate towards the former
blueprints but don't feel compelled if
you see something you like go for it the
blue bar next to the potential loot
depicts the probability of an item
dropping and of course the rarer stuff
is harder to get your hands on I'm going
to pick this rally and look it has no
chance of dropping former please
remember that so what's next get your
backside over to the navigation panel
and look in the top right hand corner on
ps4 press the r-1 button until you see
void fissure
avoid for Cyril's ears if you've never
heard the word before the little icon
resembles fire these missions are
randomized and rotate in and out so
check back here for different missions
regularly these are just run-of-the-mill
levels with an added incentive to pick
up ten reactants which randomly drop out
of debt enemies these in turn will open
the relic at the end of the mission if
it's a successful mission of course
remember when I deliberately chose a
relic which didn't have a former option
well at the end of the mission you have
the choice to pick from anyone's relics
in the mission so former will almost
certainly always be an option if you
choose to go down that route alternately
do what the heck you like farm for a
frame or weapon parts void relics have
much more to offer than this but for
this episode I think we're done here
we'll progressed a little further next
time
next let's go farming for a warframe we
can hop on the market and search for
almost any warframe we want to build
let's look at one at random what about
NYX and yep there she is ready to buy
for platinum or credits and what about
Octavia well she can be purchased here
for platinum which of course we are not
ever going to do but her warframe is not
here to buy as a blueprint looking more
closely she is linked to a quest and her
components can be found on Lua what have
we learned from this the market is a
useful place for information about
warframes who would have bloody thunk it
anyway the warframe we want is Rhino as
he's probably the easiest friend to
obtain early on in your journey and he
still has a use in later game so I'm
told we can purchase him for platinum
which is not going to happen at all
and alternately we can press star 1 and
buy the blueprint instead to build Rhino
we will need Rhino near optics Rhino
chassis Rhino systems and we will also
need to get our hands on some gallium so
why the heck do we find the blueprints
for neurotics chassis and systems well
it's from a single mission over on Venus
and the node fossa this is an
assassination mission or a boss
encounter if you prefer we are going to
kill the jackal a mechanical Quadra pet
with specific things to shoot I'll show
you this in a mixture of solo and team
play but I'd really recommend doing this
publicly as there's usually a high level
player around farming parts who will
kill the boss in around 2 seconds in the
mission fossa get your backside over to
the boss as quickly as possible once the
Jackals intro animation is out of the
way back away behind one of these
pillars simply pop out from behind and
shoot one of his legs once he falls his
head becomes his weak spot so damage it
as much as you can apart from the
occasional shockwave you'll need to jump
over and the constant flying enemies to
be aware of that's it
standing behind the pillar prevents most
of the shock waves from hitting you
rinse and repeat and then get to
extraction try to bring a weapon with
punctured damage values as the jackal is
an armored fall down assassination
complete great work Tara if you're lucky
enough you will have the chassis new
optics are systems in your possession
complete the mission multiple times to
get all the parts once that's done and
out of the way over in the foundry we
can have a look at this in more detail
all three Rhino parts must be created
before we can go on to create the fully
functioning Rhino warframe everything
you need to build each segment should
already be in your possession but if it
isn't
use the navigation hood and press r3 on
each planet to find out where is the
best place to go to pick up those
resources now activate your 3d printer
and come back in 12 hours don't rush it
with platinum just wait for it is worth
it I promise
12 long hours later our parts are ready
to be assembled but we still require
galium an early spot to grab this is by
defeating Crill on Mars it's found on
the wall note his weak spot is his
coolant tank by the way okay back to our
forge and our very last step let's make
Rhino it'll take your 3d printer three
days to complete this task please don't
use your Platinum to rush it once you've
wasted those agonizing 72 hours
yah-hoo our frame is here and now you
can say you earned that warframe so go
wreck [ __ ] with it now anyway let's
talk about what we should be doing with
that platinum we have in our back pocket
as we all know by now platinum is the
most powerful commodity in warframe
trade chat is full of people buying and
selling items in return for platinum the
reason we haven't looked into it yet is
because at this point in our journey
we'd likely buy something we could
easily farm for which is the reason we
play warframe in the first place we will
look at how to make platinum in future
episodes but for now let's lay it on the
line
what the heck should I buy with platinum
easy warframe and weapon slots warframe
allows you to find and create so many
items that we don't have enough space to
hold them without platinum we have one
single option selling our stuff if
you're a hoarder like me or a collector
that will sound horrible to hear but at
any point you could craft another
version of anything you sell but of
course you will have to obtain a
blueprint again and farm all the parts
and also level it all the way up to 30
again the
turn ative is to use platinum to
purchase a slot or a place to put those
items when you've got them there's a few
ways to do this when your foundry has
completed its workload and you decide to
claim a weapon you'll receive a prompt
asking you to buy extra slots my advice
is simple go for it it's exactly the
same way the warframe if you don't have
a slot free you'll either need to bend
one of your current frames or purchase a
new slot for this one
at present the slots cost twelve
platinum per weapon and twenty for a new
warframe slot to purchase them in
advance press options and go down to
your inventory here's everything you
have to have across using our one two
warframes or weapons as I've already
said weapons cost twelve plus and twenty
for a new warframe slot buy them here if
you're afraid you may spend platinum
somewhere accidentally by the way in
here is also where you can retire and
sell unwanted war frames and weaponry
and that's what I suggest you do with
your platinum oh my word this episode
has been rather mechanic heavy so let's
do something a little more lighthearted
to end
have you noticed my ship interior
continually changes in warframe vanity
is everything and having a home you want
to spend time in is equally as important
we all have the ability to customise our
ships but of course the game doesn't
tell us how to do that very well it's
pretty simple on ps4 click options
equipment landing craft and then go nuts
with the options you can also change the
external colors of your ship for those
loading screen moments warframe is
hoping you see a color you don't already
own like those freaking brilliant neons
and the only way to get them yeah it's
through platinum so buy it and damn I'm
really thinking about doing that
decorations can also be put around your
ship like a makeshift ceiling fan for my
Cooper just have fun with it and make
warframe the experience you want it to
be let's call episode 2 a wrap there we
still have so much to talk about but
let's not rush things too far I'm Adam
from PlayStation granade it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time
you